bonjour à tous on aura présenté le
successeur du micro le honor view dix
nouveaux smartphones qui a annoncé comme
étant un concurrent direct de l'iphone
disent je suis pas vraiment d'accord
avec ce point et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi aux trois minutes dans trois
minutes tech
[Musique]
on lance au compteur côté design il
exact assez classique un dos en métal
c'est facile a vraiment un avantage de
ne pas laisser de traces de doigts
l'arrière un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui était passé à l'avant de
l'appareil en bas de l'écran un
smartphone qui est très fin il fait 6,97
mm alors que l'iphone d'isf et 7,7 mm et
le galaxy note 8 8 6 mm il al'avantage
d'avoir un grand écran 5,24 à 19 pouces
fhd plus en 2160 par 1080 pixels au
format 18 9e avec une résolution de 403
ppp c'est une dalle ips1 écran lcd qui
occuperait plus de 85% de la face avant
que tu ailles photo il à l'arrière un
double capteur 1/2 20 mégapixels
monochrome et un 16 mégapixels couleurs
avec une ouverture de 1.8
côté photo selphy il est un capteur de
13 mégapixels en façade il dispose du
mode portrait à l'avant comme à
l'arrière grâce aux étoiles doit de
portraits on peut changer le fond vous
êtes chez vous vous êtes à new york alon
où vous voulez ça c'est très sympa ce
gadget mais c'est sympa et il filme en
4k uhd côté processeur on trouve un
kirin 970 cadencé à 2,36 gigahertz une
puce graphique mali j'ai 72 m p 12 il a
six giga de ram et il à 128 gigaoctets
de stockage
alors bien évidemment vous pouvez
rajouter une carte mémoire pour monter
le stockage
il dispose d'une puce npa neuronale
processing unit qui sert à la
reconnaissance des images ce qui fait
que si vous allez prendre en photo un
chien un chat de la nourriture nous quoi
que ce soit il devrait il reconnaître et
pouvoir vraiment optimiser la qualité de
vos photos idem lorsque vous êtes en
déplacement voulait par exemple des
caractères que vous ne connaissez pas du
cyrillique du chinois il le prend en
photo et grâce à un partenariat avec
microsoft il va vous le traduire et vous
pourrez effectivement comprendre le
texte
il ya également un partenariat qui était
annoncé avec des directs pour piloter
vos drones uniquement à la voie côté
autonomie il a une batterie 3750 millan
terreur qui devrait complètement absorbé
la consommation du processeur et aussi
la taille du grand écran de quasiment 6
pouces il dispose d'une prise jack domme
bluetooth 4 points 2
le lecteur d'empreintes digitales en
façade sert de bouton home mais aussi le
bouton retour et de boutons multitâche
lors de la présentation était montré un
mode de déverrouillage pas sale qui a
été un vrai bide
il n'a pas marché pour des raisons 2
auzits et donc ça veut dire pas de
capteur infrarouge ça veut dire une
reconnaissance faciale basée uniquement
sur la photo donc ça en terme de
sécurité
ça reste à voir ils ont annoncé une
optimisation du son grâce à des micros
qui vont capter le son extérieur et qui
vont améliorer la qualité audio pour
réduire vraiment les nuisances il tourne
sous android
8 oreo avec une surcouche emotion 8.0 il
est disponible dans deux coloris le noir
et le bleu alors est-ce que le ono
review 10 peut rivaliser avec l'iphone
10 pour moi très clairement non c'est un
téléphone qui sur le papier en tout cas
très séduisant mais il n'a pas d'écran
oled
il n'a pas de caméra trop d'eps il n'a
pas un écran qui occupe la totalité de
la face avant du smartphone même sur le
plan pratique sans l'iphone disent vous
avez une petite encoche en eau au niveau
de la caméra trop d'eps mais c'est
vraiment des caractéristiques qui font
en tout cas la force de cet iphone 10 il
serait plutôt un concurrent direct du
one + 5 t il reprend les sens du hoyoux
emma 10 pro en beaucoup moins cher même
processeur double caméra arrière sans le
partenariat avec les cas et avec un
design beaucoup moins élégant en
attendant au moins de plus c'est
tranquille avec 120 +5 t pour la fin de
l'année parce que ceux au nord view 10
ne sortira qu'à partir du 8 janvier au
tarif de 499 euros coup voilà un petit
peu ce qu'on peut dire en trois minutes
sur ceux au nord view 10 dites nous ce
que vous en pensez est-ce que ça
smartphones que vous trouvez sur le
papier intéressant est ce que vous
pensez qu'il va réellement concurrencer
l'iphone disent oui non pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez un téléphone de well aware
et mc 10 pro qu'est ce que vous pensez
tout ça est ce que ce nouveau smartphone
peut vous intéresser
est ce que ces fonctionnalités vous les
trouvez séduisante et surtout est-ce que
pour moins de 500 euros vous pourrez
vous laisser tenter
dites moi ce que vous en pensez aux
commentaires je vous invite à laisser
des gens qui poussent à vous abonner
passera toujours toujours toujours plus
de contenu pour parler de high tech de
nouvelles technologies de plein de
choses il ya des surprises qui vous
attendent
merci à vous soyez sages portez vous
bien et je vous dis à très bientôt avec
deux nouvelles vidéos ça